I think at first they don't know if I'm
a person of faith because i don't i
really don't say it unless asked and but
what i do do is i take i have a prayer
partner that I take with me and he's a
good friend he's he's he's an older man
he's older than me and he goes with me
every place I've been that North Korea
six or seven times I go all over the
world he goes with me and he we get up
every morning we pray together and you
know we read the scriptures and it says
in the Paul when he wrote his letter to
the Thessalonians says in the first
chapter he said when Timothy and I and
solve anus when we wrote this letter he
said when we came we had the Holy Spirit
we had power and we had true conviction
he said and will we come that way it's
amazing when you go when two or more of
you go together like that you go with
great power and strength and I find that
some of the most simple things that God
says we kind of miss you know God says
love your enemy says feed the poor
just love your neighbor he says when two
or more gathered together I'm there he
says when you go out like that go out
two by two you know we kind of like to
make god complex you know we get a lot
of theories for him and a lot of
philosophies and miss and thank you
telling us can there laughing a Jill I
hit him I'm not talking about you but
anyway normally by the time the trip is
over because we pray together like one
time we were in the Congo if people saw
that we were get up you know they won't
know what my friend and I were doing
early in the mornings and while we were
just praying together by the time we
left because we had a we always had a
large group go with us we have paid zand
we'd had people that were helping us and
guides and then we had security thinking
the Congo we had 19 people that were
joining us for prayer time in the
morning just buy them asking what we
were doing well we just prayed can we
come yeah when I got home Anna I was
ambassador I had an email this was
people in the Congo and they said you
know because as an ambassador you came
and prayed with us we felt that if you
can do that with us we've decided we're
going to continue that process and do
that here so I mean you don't have to
shove it down people's throats you don't
have to make a sermon you can just show
it and people will see it you don't have
to tell people who you are you'll see
and you know what you might get some
pushback but at least you don't have to
proselytize matter of fact in some
countries you're not allowed it's
illegal and in those countries you
should obey the law of the land so says
you don't proselytize don't proselytize
that's the law
what that doesn't say you can't pray in
private